Uh, last time, you wrote to us that you
enjoyed the uh, live and the um,
precise answers and I know um, many of
you, you have requested to clip those
um, objections and responses to the
objections and put it out. We already
tell you, you can do that. Just make
sure um, you put uh, brother Sam's
channel and my channel in the
description of the video. That's all we
ask. And uh, there're not going to be no
no no copyrights or strikes. So, uh,
take advantage of it. People need to
hear this. Post it on YouTube, social
media, Facebook, Instagram, all over the
place. People need to hear
uh, the responses to these objections
and questions. So, by the grace of God,
let's pray and get it started. Father,
we thank you in the name of the Lord
Jesus for this opportunity that you give
us that we can uh,
uh, bring clarity to these uh,
subjects, to these objections, to these
questions that people might have. We
thank you, Father, that you give my
brother Sam
the mind, the spirit, the preparation
and you have called him for such a for
such a time as this. We thank you,
Father, that you have uh, enabled us to
do these things. You have given us
internet uh, and all of these equipments
that we can do this. We thank you,
Father, for that. Use this to bring
glory to your kingdom, to your son and
by the grace of God, you give us a
speaking utterance that we can speak
with clarity. In Jesus name, I pray.
Amen. Amen. Awesome. Bless you and me
and the Holy Spirit. Strengthen my
throat with health and destroy any
demonic attack. Purify us with the blood
of Jesus Christ and give us perfect
recall of scripture and facts in Jesus
name. Brother,
you're from Iran. Before we begin, Mhm.
what do you say is happening right now?
Even though they got rid of the
Ayatollah, Yeah. as someone who's an
Iranian
and someone who was a Shia,
what does this mean for the Iranians in
Iran?
This um, Um, so last month, brother, we
went through massive
executions. Yeah. Uh, we went through
massive, uh, uprising and of course, the
regime, uh, responded with brutality. I
mean, unimaginable savagery that you
cannot even find in the 7th centuries.
And, um, they killed thousands, tens of
thousands of Iranians, uh,
uh, blinded many of them because they
were shooting into the crowd by shotguns
with, um,
and, uh, blinding, uh, up or of 10,000
people have been blinded.
Um, the they say the injuries to about
350,000 people have been injured for
life.
And, um,
um, I remember, um,
that, uh, many of the believers,
Christians, Iranian Christians who work
in the hospitals, they said they stormed
the hospitals, this, uh, this government
stormed the hospitals. And if you were
injured injured in the in on a on on the
doctors were trying to keep you alive,
they will execute you on those, uh,
hospital beds. It's, um, unimaginable
things. So, many Iranians, uh,
uh, lost their loved ones, they lost
their lives, and and many families were
grieving already, and they would,
brother Sam, they would come out, um,
on the TV, this regime would come out,
this Muslims, this clerics come out on
the on the TV and call chapter 2 of the
Quran, I think it's verse 193 or 197
that Allah has commanded us to
kill as many, to completely, uh, abolish
and destroy, uh, discord that is among
Muslims. So, they would kill us, and
they would tell us that we we have been
commanded by Allah.
And, um,
we were waiting for the West to to step
in. Uh, the Iranian people had the will,
but they didn't have the weapons
because,
uh, the the the government has all the
weapons and machineries and every, uh,
uh, thing you could imagine, and the
Iranian people are completely unarmed.
And, um,
uh, so they had the willingness to go
out, protest, to take over, uh, maybe
get some rights from this regime, but
the answer was always bullets.
Um they made the
Iranian families who went to pick up
their dead, they would make him to uh to
to pay
for the bullets that they killed
those people.
So,
it was heart-wrenching. People were
losing hope and of course um
President Trump promised Iranian people
got guns are locked and loaded, we're on
the way. And Iranian uh because he
promised them, they they were
emboldened, they went on the streets and
they stayed on the street and many got
killed and they realized
it wasn't, you know,
as quick as they anticipated. And I
believe now I see it
uh hindsight that um
I think
Trump got President Trump uh
jumped the gun and um
uh
he told the Iranian people to go on the
streets, occupy
the institutions and things of that
nature, but I don't think they were
America was ready or Israel was ready or
the
they were
their mobilization was complete
complete, but anyway
uh last night they started attacking um
the first place they hit was the palace
of the Ayatollah Khamenei,
uh him, his successor, which was his
son, and four the other members of the
cabinet of him that they uh
uh ordered the killing of the Iranian
and they all were killed on in one
attack. Um
the um the defense secretary, the
IRGC's replacement
General many, they say many of these
leaders have have died and we had
internet
till about early morning yesterday.
Uh the first thing of course my brother
shoot me text was that
the attacks has already had the war has
already begun. And then of course
internet is shut shut down again, so we
don't know what actually going on other
than
what
is in the news here in the West, but um
um many Iranian people as soon as they
heard
the
uh the death of the Khamenei, the
death of the supreme leader, they came
on the streets. The videos were coming
out. They're celebrating.
It's just It's like
finally after 47 years of oppression, 47
years of
Islamic sharia, of
uh seven centuries savagery, finally
this man paid
a little bit a little bit of what he
brought to the Iranian people. So, um
the tide is is turning. The the prince
of Iran uh the son of the shah
is talking about when it's time he's
going to help the transition and the
Iranian people will vote for the new
government that is going to replace this
regime. But, the government that the um
the the prince is talking about it is
going to be
pro-West and pro-minorities, especially
religious minorities. And it's going to
be un-Islamic, uh the separation of
Islam from from That's what the Iranian
people want from the state. So, that's
some some of the stuff that is
happening, brother. I can talk a whole
lot more about that. Yeah. The I was
wondering
only that we're going to get in topic,
but because I'm curious, what if this
only brings
another
leader to continue Islamic regime?
What's the guarantee that's not going to
happen? That's what I was wondering. Oh,
absolutely. I I understand. It could be
a vacuum. It could be Iraq. It could be
Afghanistan. But, you have to know that
um
the Persian people, they're done with
Islam. That's That's the good news
because um
in 2020,
50,000 Iranians were asked the question,
"What's your religious affiliation?" And
less than 1/3 they even identify as Shia
Muslims. Less than 1/3.
And in 2023,
the Ayatollah uh high uh official in the
in the president's government uh in the
president administration came out and
said, "50,000 of the mosques out of the
75 mosques 75,000 mosques that exist in
Iran, they have been already closed.
Iranians religion is dead in Iran." So,
we were on a uh
trip
trajectory of
walking away. The Iranian people,
Persian people walk away from Islam. And
then in 2026 during the protest, the
Iranian were burning down mosques and
shrines and Qurans. So, this was sho-
showing the dissolution. It's not only
for with the regime, it's with Islam
itself. And um
I think um
uh
we don't have that we're not in a in a
situation such as Iraq that you remove
the government and we don't have a
replacement. The the the the um Pahlavi
Reza Pahlavi, the prince of Iran
has been always there. His father
was the ruler over Iran. His grandfather
was the ruler of Iran. So, the family
has been there. We just had a 47 years
gap, which by the grace of God they're
going to return. And um
it's um
we won't we won't have the uh problem
that other nations have because the
Persians are not like they're not they
don't want sharia anymore or they don't
want to deal with Islam or they
understand they they have transitioned
from that mentality for sure that they
had 50 years ago.
Let's see what the Lord will have happen
in Iran. Let's see. I hope I hope it's
toppled and now they're free to worship
Jesus and no more persecution. Let's
>> Absolutely. And the church of Iran is
going to be
uh coming from the underground to the
over the ground, brother. It's um we're
talking about millions of Iranian
believers that um the forefront. Yep,
that's what we're hoping. Once the
Islamic regime collapses and there's
freedom of religion
Christianity will explode. By the the of
God. We see that, really. Um I've been a
Christian 20 years now, and I've seen
how many Muslims
have left Islam, how many Iranians have
left Islam. It's just exciting times.
It's exciting times, brother.
Glory to God. All right, brother. Glory
to God. Let's help let's let's use of
the spirit to help people leave Islam
and show why Islam is false Jesus is
God. So, what's going on? Amen. Amen.